perhaps it's time to go home the south
doesn't seem to agree with you
i know the truth jon arryn died for
do you lord stark is that why you called
me here to pose me riddles
has he done this before
jamie would have killed him my brother's
worth a thousand of your friend
your brother or your lover
targaryens were brothers and sisters for
300 years to keep bloodlines pure
jamie and i are more than brother and
sister we shared a womb
came into this world together we belong
together
my son saw you with him
do you love your children with all my
heart no more than i love mine and
they're all james
thank the gods in the rare event that
rob leaves his [ __ ] for long enough to
stumble drunk into my bed i finish him
off in other ways
in the morning he doesn't remember
you've always hated him
hated him i worshipped him
every girl in the seven kingdoms dreamed
of him but it was mine by oath
and when i finally saw him on our
wedding day in the set of baylor
lean and fierce and blackbeard it was
the happiest moment of my life
and that night he crawled on top of me
stinking of wine and did what he did
what little he could do
and whispered in my ear lyanna
your sister was a corpse and i was a
living girl and he loved her more than
me
when the king returns from his hunt i'll
tell him the truth
you must be gone by then you and your
children
i will not have their blood on my hands
go as far away as you can
with as many men as you can because
wherever you go
robert's roth will follow you i'm one of
my ruffled stark
you should have taken the realm for
yourself jamie told me about the day
king's landing fell
he was sitting in the iron throne and
you made him give it up all you needed
to do was climb the steps yourself
such a sad mistake i've made many
mistakes in my life
but that wasn't one of them oh but it
was
when you play the game of thrones you
win or you die
there is no middle ground
you